are you all
right are you sure
[Music]
k
keep the same patterns
it just takes my more more micro
adjustments along the way
can't save them for the
end
yes then make sure you're
pushing push
[Music]
and then balling your feet at the end
okay you need to stay
standing okay so you have to you have to
get on the angle some
way get on the
Ang
notation on the
line if I has to rotate boom he goes
around
then I have to now do the
armack so I have one more turn this way
can do it easy for now but the pattern
is
there but the
angle he goes around
me then I turn it in
him right away shoulder
down he goes around
gv8 into the
center around
you you get pushes pushing try to knock
them down
[Music]
other way don't move into the other hold
the
other
[Music]
for
for for
[Music]
you
here's the trading YY CL I have to get
rid of
it and I have to clear the
line
so I Parry to the left I move to the
right then I feed his action
Parry to the left move to the
right
his when you Fe his action it is again
the TW so I here
I also have to get out of the shoulder
don't go his
shoulder capture his body
you can add
minut part
you have to uh things he's not spinally
displacing you don't move to uh a set
position you move to reconcile the young
energy you have a couple options you
love that spot you have to tell him I
push through push through he's not
pushing through probably don't have to
yield that far okay try it again but you
do know you have to be able to capture
the center and you can't
[Music]
use the quad off the shoulder don't
bring your elbow outside your oper
what's happening happen
you stop doing things you need in the
middle on the teacher
still M so as I
move if I only move
here and I come around and I keep K I'm
never going to get that very Awkward on
you so what do you do is you go here and
now this is very weak okay so your Kate
is going to tell you how far are you
away from him how far do I come out to
the side I come out so there's no
pressure on Kate it's where it fits I'm
not driving into him I'm not overing
him this easy into the body
I go to zero pressure that's how far I
come out I keep the same elbow Bend then
the qu
Works no pressure right here then the
qual
[Music]
works kind of jam
okay try it
again much
maret turn the quad
turn the thumb
down
[Music]
better inward spiral
head of
him for
[Music]
the hand shape is exactly
like maybe
that's looks like
this like you're turning a
St okay all right you can take any
number ways on
this but if you let him on this part you
then you can add his initial spinal
displacement his shoulder
H they go past now you're on the back
side of
this you can do it at any
angle but let's work on that one
[Music]
y the
PA go with
long shoulder pass
spiral shoulder
pass okay
is
spiral almost straight in the
AR
spiral
yes it'll do it for
you you with
him on the inside of his
[Music]
you use this use this get out of this
should go slow enough for your mind to
use some discipline to get away from the
ego
okay now so now we can go back to your
question was he making you roll or did
you op to
roll if he's making you roll I should
see a counter force on the bottom
side if I don't see a counter force on
the bottom
side you're not being made to
look rolling is a topsy turby AC here is
the a side here is the B
side Topsy turby is when the aide hits
the minimum b side or goes past it got
it
okay if I
just drw the a
side and never in a million years will
have come this
way if I kick both
sides then it has to and never in a
million
years got in will the bide H you
understand now I made the spit
just like yesterday's
technique by lowering the head you see
and this Force popping up is
this and never good in
yours can you go face
down this
way those two energies are
likewise he's there when he rolls over
he often should do that
[Music]
okay so here it's a crash it is a de but
he should take the
CR he shouldn't do anything I do things
to him and he lets me do those things to
him
okay try it
again keep your grip there was no disarm
or strip of the grip you keep your
for
okay we're in the ballpark now so start
using your claw and start getting out of
the
shoulder
go keep good hand
spirals not straight lines
get in there Center
find the heaviest
part because you're going with it push
the heaviest part go keep going you're
in that shoulder you have to try
[Music]
that's not a spiral
sh from the qua close the seams
is
[Music]
okay let's look at the Y hand the one
you've been
using one more
turn into the
elbow spir one more turn and
boom boom one more turn into the
elbow when you do this don't bring your
elbow
back here one more
turn without moving the
[Music]
elbow don't gra it clear
don't let go because we haven't done
anything don't fall
off get him to go past you
got kind of
jam
secret your AR slightly change each
Direction each each instruction you give
you change it every
time don't let your
elbow that's
[Music]
it you don't let
escape the
[Music]
dri thumb on the inside and start on the
inside then that will take to the
outside start on the inside of this
hand then one more turn see like this
there you
go one morein one more spin one more
spin this one more of these
coordinate your Emi with the
elbow all right so let's stand up and
watch a little more
closely there's a couple things
okay uh all things being equal you want
the inside of a fight you don't want him
to have the inside of the fight you're
on the
outside so I'm going to clear the
line I'm going to attempt what I'm doing
on the
inside see I'm on the inside don't block
your own work by being on the
outside you're on the
inside okay
turn one more
there is the elbow and I now don't reach
I move just like the Joe Ste the body
moves and you're
out so the first thing is stay on the
inside on the first
move second move attack the outside how
one more turn and waight move the
body like the Jo ski
don't now let's look at his
grip
okay there's his grip he's grabbing
pretty hard I can't take this off that
wouldn't be iido even if I could so I
come around
and you start to make it look already
like
e then you push through
that I imagine you can go like this if
he lets
go but he's not weak in it there is the
n right
here you push through
and you do that with the
first coordinate your
sides you're coordinating knee quaw
hand elbow shoulder all in
alignment hold it
in you don't open your GP open your G
[Music]
inside the
outside don't it down
yet just clear the hand that's all we're
doing
[Music]
don't push
away
spiral
Spiral here
does it now leave it
there push like you're pushing a wall
here with your to
the let's get our
mind try each time a little bit more of
the Techni
just going to swallow your wrist you
always want to push on but you don't of
yourself as a just leave it there just
leave it there don't leave it
there now step and it goes to the elbows
yes right
here yes that's the technique
[Music]
same feel the drop feel the drop
when you you come back
back now going FAS
okay I have two hands in this
technique when can this hand become
active yep got
it you
[Music]
can have it here take your hand the
other hand and it'll catch
release if you feel so
compos you can lay there but you can't
use
it discarding or
trapping so I'm not using
it I push through and it catches the
other so rather than
this I am catching a disarmed
okay do your
best thank you very
much do your best don't use
it you catching the hand not the
great this arm catch that's it
got
jamed too much pressor
Chris the spiral so you don't touch the
forearm do the disarm
[Music]
use your thumb on the inside that's part
of the disarm
turn it over there's
two there's one do it
[Music]
again push
hey we're in the ballpark so clean it
all up
[Music]
spe
spal fireal
one more push it
through you have a certain way to
have
okay let's look at
the come closer
this knuckle
here is going to push on this flange of
his
thumb so that it goes
in don't try to use your hand if it was
big enough and capture it use that
knuckle to stop it from going out okay
if you have a big hand that could grab
it you're just that much better off with
that
middle the
pinky is a forr
point for this angle
here your palm stays
connected don't over squeeze or your
palm will cut and on my finger
FS just stay connected just like the
bend
okay so when you
it that's where that knuckle goes right
there the pinky goes at the top of the
wrist around there it is the this arm
you have the hand position in that's
where you set yourself into that
position don't let the fingers open the
two hands are working to keep the right
angle in the wrist
not your wrist grip
straight out thumb knuckle
here there it is keep it on this move
the El the shoulder goes down the hand
does not okay
[Music]
okay we have the hand and we have the
now we're emphasizing the shoulders down
the hand is not
Che for
[Music]
get the hand in
place his
fingers don't put his hand
down put the hand up up above where your
uh seam is don't put it on the ground
yet
your your hands at the clock that the H
hand is at least the height of the clock
not Below on your thighs all
right and being K you have a front knee
and the back knee is at 90 to the front
knee
your are
[Music]
sare don't PE peel it push through it
down hands
above come
up two locks here first one is the wrist
push the wrist in second lock is the
elbow push it against
the capture the hand in the s
first one push the fingers up the
shoulder second one push the
elbow this
way okay uh I don't care if you
transition quickly to there but when you
start to apply both of them very slowly
and then tap quickly okay
don't bend your arm keep it in katate
and you push your the arm with your body
it's not about how strong you feel it's
how how how strong you feel to him you
bend your arms you're going to feel like
you're flexing a lot cuz you're doing a
lot more work to get nothing he just
wasn't even going to to that okay do the
other one you barely move and you tap
right away
okay if you're feeling your power you're
not powerful the powerful don't feel
those HS
B
push him down shoulder down with the
left knee shoulder down with the left
knee it down put your left knee in front
then step with your right foot
underneath the wrist
one more turn there it is now push his
shoulder
down put it all the way down on the
ground good now step underneath his
right wrist there it is stay there
you're going to be on your knee so put
your foot flat
put your foot back and lift his arm up
into that crease of your thigh yes okay
now push his fingers up your shoulder
slowly not not not turning just there
it you ready to catch it and catch it
the right
way there you go now first you have to
pin him down you're getting ahead of
yourself you have to use that inside
KNE that inside
KN smash it down you see I can't use
this knee back here and then try to use
this there's no there's no weight on
there
okay it's on after he here that's when I
go and attack okay
one
two okay so make sure that shoulder gets
down that is the nature of the pin the
homolateral shoulder that means the same
side shoulder to me is boom down on the
ground now I created an angle
cancellation against where I'm standing
free if his shoulder is up I can't get
it down ditch the technique okay I try
it again thank you very no one's
resisting C it
and pin him nope nope he's not down yet
use your other knee use your other knee
put that leg
back and keep that side
forward and now use the claw of your
left
side yes now step underneath his there
it is
[Music]
yes all right so uh people don't just
let you break their limbs it's weird
that way okay
so when I go here you going to feel that
tighten you feel that okay I'm just
keeping it loose E that you get not an
opponent but there's a lot of
pressure okay and it's not me doing this
it's me raising it with my leg you see
okay and there's this action right with
my body pull away
you
see do that you it's not resting here
I'm trapping it in that seam okay
there's a there's a lot of pinching
right okay that's where I
do the wrist which you can't even tell
I'm
moving do the
arm okay so if my movement
in ideal conditions is
imperceivable when I that wrist is
breaking you see that elbow is breing
okay got it you understand if it takes
big movements I'm not in the right place
it's too loose there's too much slack
being taken out that should have been
taken out before I go for the okay
not asking you to break each other just
asking you to get ready to
slap instead
of you you drop the
as opposed to
top the wrist El
first
find do each move
how you see move forward you see that's
where I want
I you be there then I have see okay
don't slur your
diction go
then
your step the hand
yes
[Music]
elbow
good when you get
here same
forward I
come you got to be grounded you got to
be ready to turn your CL back don't do
it I just did the pressure
okay first down then around same thing
don't slurp down then
around okay
in
training does not do anything he's not
trying to stop me nor trying to give it
to me he's just going to hi there
okay he doesn't
smell that he should roll himself over
you see go ahead and do it no the other
face down you shouldn't do I didn't do
that get it I did not do that
he's hanging out there cuz I'm going to
bring him this
way and the more he rolls himself over
I'm going to smash his face you see so
as he's trying to do that that gets all
that pressure on
you I want to do that to the guy on the
street but I don't want to do it to my
UK okay this goes down under
round okay that's where this
is because I'm not fighting his arm I'm
not fighting his
arm through his arm touching his
Center through the arm Center
Center
okay let us come back from the two
breaks and work on this part hey go
[Music]
move it
around is just more conditioning for you
move it around already move it around
yes that's
not the same
footwork it's that you don't start
turning him until you're at the very end
you need to start turning him from the
very beginning because it's a sputter
right it's not a straight line away from
you
okay when you push up to the Elbow it is
on a
spiral that's
it see my push straight
through one more running this is the bad
side when you go to the Elbow it's on
the spiral on spiral on the spiral yeah
it doesn't have to leave him
up again that
side on the
spiral yes and it goes
down that would be a straight line you
see Taylor that's a straight line
make him go around you but you enter
that knee under his shoulder that's
it we're leaving that off for
now you got one more wrist flip to
do ni
no don't smell
it
good don't smell it don't
go got you okay it goes
around this way
yes don't kill
yourself going this way around you see
boom boom not straight it's turning
turning turning
boom turning turning
turning
boom
okay don't take that extra step
get your hand ready you're going to need
it that's
it he's going to come around get your
hand ready get
your come around there you go
not doing doing
a
yes it was uh not spiraling down not
spiraling down just circling around
you can go slow if you feel like his
arms getting really tight just go slow
just go slow
don't lower the hand
the don't lower the hand beneath the CL
seam only one
step I'm going to get you there I'll get
you the last step you don't have to
worry we'll get
there you have to go
forward let's try
Chris I'm going to go slow if you get TR
you can say tap tap tap okay what what
happens when I do this
maneuver is that I am tightening all of
those shoulder
joints so that when I come
around there's a break you see remember
on the last one you could walk up fre
when I tighten all this and I don't like
goow that shoulder and I walk forward
I'll do it
slowly got it that's the last step here
where we let UK out and let him
move so we can do the first
move and then release it to do the last
and let him move around so he doesn't
get his s
injured then let pressure off if you
didn't let pressure off when
you stepped around boom off comes the
arm
okay so we're here pressure off on the
elbow and come around and let him move
with
you pressure off move
around
okay try
you're still going to do the first that
the the tightening on the
circle then you let it
go then you let it go and they'll move
with you to take pain off their
shoulder they'll Circle CC around with
you why it's a simple answer why will
they circle around with
you because they can and letting them so
they should move where they're not
getting injured you
see okay try it
again don't lay on the ground like a
victim
and release it moves with
you then release it more than
that more just let you let it go of the
elbow pressure and just move her hand
around she moves way to
Margaret move your move your whole body
turn your
pal you're going to want to do weird
things you don't let people do that
you're at that level now you can go slow
without okay you don't do your things
when you feel your energ you take to the
left you move to the left you don't
smell the barn like a horse a rental you
get it you smell the ground and you're
like I just lay here I'm going to tap
and this is all over you go where you're
being
taken it's got to get more around you
can't have the the D by and not
what are you waiting
for turn around you not down on his
nose then release the elbow and let him
move with
you good then
release the
why you came up on I need to do that you
see and now it jacked up your ripping up
the arm you already spent that
L turn around you laugh now release him
walk around up his
arm that's
it all right so
yesterday yesterday went ring through me
okay I like this
I don't want to segment I have my
organization I keep my
organization up he
throws keep my organization he going to
do the
technique I have my organization it's
right
there I have my
organization right here he
goes boom he moves I let him move my
whole body okay here here we go he comes
around and he's going to move my whole
body CU I'm organized go back I'm not
segmented through the Torso to the
pelvis and he comes around and go like
that
connected okay
keep your organization never lie and go
flat de pressu oned okay even when
you're being pinned you're
not you're organized
this is going to make more weight for
them to move this is going to train them
as it keeps you
safer move
Sean move as a unit just lock your body
[Music]
your
your your rib cage
okay all right we had this technique
this
morning here right there remember that
okay that Mo looks mechanical but it's
not my Che is dropping I'm projecting
down we had makio to I'm dropping the
chi same thing
here and I come to the end around let
him
out and I drop it on the right
hand release release everything just
like Z on day one all my muscles drop if
it hurts on him he can let go if if it's
ever hurting okay but I'm not trying to
hurt him I'm just making that hand heavy
through releasing tension you're going
to try to lift the elbow up if he feels
my weight there he Taps okay it's not
he's trying to pick me up he just
checked my weights there out here lift
it up you would no okay get on my hand
and I release the
tension let them
out
drop release all the
muscles when you have the EO grip you
keep the EO grip when you have the wrist
you come to the elbow in the triangle
shape we have the EO grip you keep the
EO grip
okay let's go let's go
[Music]
you try to lift so you to check his
weights there then you tap don't injure
yourself when you check for weight
that's
[Music]
it round you down let him
out release tension into the right hand
[Music]
turn I turn to your left with your right
left foot with your right CL
[Music]
only 15 very very
noticeable out and then go
[Music]
forward let him out be sure you let him
out of that elbow
pressure have to let his shoulder be
free
[Music]
Sean you going to defer to the gu
round two let him out one more step
around
yep sink your release your muscle
tension all muscle tension just like day
one
zed and that left hand will be
heavy H thank each other